the redesigned m2 macbook air is going  to be amazing but is it worth waiting  for it or should you just buy the  current m1 macbook air the new m2  macbook air overall it will be a smaller  machine it is also very possible that  the m2 chip is gonna be based off of the  a16 processor in this case our single  core score will be over 2000 and that is  just jaw-dropping performance i  personally think that we might not even  get an m2 macbook air this year we also  have the possibility of there not being  an m2 macbook air we know this machine  is coming but will they call it the  macbook air i think if they're doing  such a big redesign they could just call  it the macbook if this thing is coming  with mini led display the redesign  magsafe i think they are going to be  raising prices for 300 bucks and this  machine will not be replaced and that is  probably the biggest reason why i think  you should not wait